[Music]
let's go to columbia south carolina
jeremy joins us there jeremy how can we
help
hey david uh sorry ken and dr john how
are you we are living the dream what's
up
uh got a question my wife and i are in
baby step two again i've talked about
you before on your show
uh like i said we're in baby step two uh
trucking pretty good we're about 12 to
18 months out from being completely
debt-free
minus a house obviously but my wife has
decided she wants to try and get a new
car which would be a major
upgrade and vehicle um
obviously that's not in the ramsay's
plan
and without you know coming across as a
jerk and you know trying to be
respectful of her
what kind of how do we navigate this
without saying i'm right you're wrong
you're right i'm wrong
you know not trying to be biased but
just say what what's better
for our future y'all have any advice on
that
i i would say first and foremost this
isn't dave's plan
this is jeremy's plan this is the plan
to change germany's house dave laid the
steps out
as long as this is an external thing
being forced on your family
by some mostly bald old man
on the radio right and i'd say that if
he was sitting here
uh i don't know yeah i would would you
um
then there's gonna be a
your wife is gonna feel imposed upon
because this isn't a joint vision
right um this is okay i'll go along with
this
guy's thing and whatever and if it keeps
my husband
hey but i want to get a new car right so
for some reason she's not fully bought
in yet
y'all aren't on the same page with this
deal were y'all at one time on the same
page what why
are we coming up with a new car here
yeah we were um we actually
downgraded both vehicles
to be able to afford them and now we're
kind of
seems like we're just making another 180
and all this has happened with them like
six months ago so it's kind of like what
i'm not even sure what's brought this
home but
you know it's not a you're crazy type
thing it's just
you know so what up here how do we go
about it
so jeremy if i'm hearing you correctly
she bought in she's like okay let's do
this baby step thing and she was
in on downgrading uh your car
so that you could pay off debt and move
along am i hearing that correctly
correct so she was on board now all of a
sudden
uh she's not ranting and raving saying
you've lost your mind i don't want to do
this she's just going
i've changed my mind again i want a nice
car is that what i'm hearing
pretty much yeah um the fact that you
say again i'm gonna throw this back to
john
from the professional counseling side
but uh just as the observer in the
conversation on this one
the fact that you just said i'm not sure
what's
changed there's part of our problem
we need to find out what is really going
on the fact that you called us and
you're not
quite sure what has changed means i
think you need to dig in a little bit
more about where she is
and and what has caused this and i'm
calling bull crap on that too jeremy
what has changed
you know oh well
one thing she starts a new job tomorrow
i'm not i'm sorry
she goes to figure out her new salary
and everything tomorrow the job change
will actually be next weekend
okay next month and that'll be she'll be
working at the same school our two girls
are gonna go to
okay um is she expecting a raise
that's kind of what i'm waiting to see
we'll hopefully we'll find that out
tomorrow
and we just don't know concrete numbers
yet i think she is
she's feeling self-conscious about
pulling up to her new job or her new
promotion with an old car
it may be so here's here's the thing i i
i think there's some stuff here the car
here is the symptom
for some reason shape form for some
reason
you all to have separated this this
mission here what you're
on together the path together and hey by
the way this happens to every married
couple on earth
about a million different things it can
happen on the way to a restaurant
hey you want to have mexican food
tonight sure that sounds great we're
headed out that way and then halfway
there it's like oh oh we're just going
to go there
like i thought we were i thought we
decided that right it happens all the
time yeah so
nothing's wrong with your marriage
nothing's wrong in your relationship but
y'all have gotten off track
and this is a time for you to flip the
lights on and turn the music off
and take her out somewhere and say hey
we all sat down
we all agreed to this we're all in we're
going to change our family tree we're
going to change the trajectory of our
our life our kids life we're all bought
in we even sold our cars and got these
two
not great cars and then you just came
and
laid this on me i you know you know i
want to provide you the best i want to
be a great provider
you've got an awesome job you're about
to get a raise it's going to accelerate
this plan
but now you say you want to get into
tell me what tell me what happened
because we were on the same page here
and bring it back to the mission bring
it back to the goal bring it back to hey
we're
in this thing together and
for god's sake this is not you guys are
the heroes of this journey
right dave wrote the plan financial
peace university we got these seven
steps
but you've got to make it y'all's vision
for your life
not dave ramsey's right sit down with
her take her and get back together on
the same page and you all create a
picture of what it's going to look like
and something you can go back to and go
back to i hope you get a she gets a
massive raise and it just accelerates
this whole thing and she'll get you go
get emergency fund and she'll get that
new car sooner rather than later
yeah i i would agree completely with
john
jeremy i would just add when you're
having this conversation let's put some
real
dates on there like you told us i forget
what you said at the beginning of the
call
but there is a payoff date if we stay
disciplined okay
so if you sit down with her and you do
all the things that john said go hey
babe listen
with this new raise we may shave three
months six months off
and at this point then we're gonna go
this many more months we got the
emergency fund in place the three to six
months
now we can begin to cash flow the car
and i can i'm gonna get you this hey put
a picture of it on the fridge yeah like
combine
her vision to the mission people will
suffer
john they'll suffer and sacrifice if
they
know where they're headed but the
ambiguity
the ambiguity in marriage is just as bad
as ambiguity in the professional setting
when a leader goes
come on everybody work those extra hours
i heard so much of this during covent
ken
they just we worked hard because of
government well the leaders never said
hey it's for three or four months yeah
just give me three and then we're gonna
get over it you gotta get clear the
ambiguity is
crushing people in the debt-free oh man
i have a goal do it together